sehr geehrte damen und herren ich habe
natürlich das intro vergessen deshalb
einmal so willkommen zu locken ist tag
[Applaus]
29 nein du bist aber etwas schönes
gekauft
das sieht aus wie chicken es aber kind
schicken
das sieht aus wie salat ist auch salat
und zu sagen es ist ein schieden salat
der fantastischen der ganzen also das
sieht einfach wirklich perfekt aus
ich liebe dieses neue stativ meine haare
sind fertig war mir heute kommt ein baby
haare blondieren ja nur den körper
tom hat gesagt ich darf meine haare
logischen heute sehr starr band
das macht man am ersten advent man
herzlich natürlich ist eine klassische
tradition ich werde sie mir nicht so
ganz
wenn man kinder hat und ich habe meine
haare nicht ganz normal natürlich muss
es ein tourist haben und ich hab sie mir
wie nazis steht wahrscheinlich schon im
titel aber ich fand es mega cool weist
darauf einfach auch sehr gespannt wie es
aussieht anzubrechen
er hat gerade sauer gesagt dass wir noch
keine adventskranz kerze an gemacht
haben
und das tun wir jetzt machen von von da
nachbarn oder von pia oder an die außen
erst und dann die inneren nein 1234
ok also flex aber unser adventskranz
sieht dieses jahr wirklich vorlage ob
sie wirklich phänomenal hoffe natürlich
dass wachsen nicht einfach so runter
gibt und alles voll macht
aber die hat schon gute kerzen geholten
glaube auch das ist schon sehr stabil
aus sind es dir
wir müssen darum drehen wir fangen dann
einfach das würde unsere vierte
wackelige kehrte sein und die kita kids
und die kita kids
[Musik]
wir werden da waren wir lassen keine
fremden eigentlich nein zugleich dieser
den angriff ihre zentren im hausflur
[Musik]
richtig machst weihnachtliche
timo hat gemacht was aber veganes machen
wir harry potter nebst klassischen
erzählt hast du schon mal wieder ein
erzähler ist ja mal wieder was es
eigentlich weniger an der weil dieser
mit den narren deswegen ist es aber
praktisch dass wir nur die unteren
blondieren weil dann ist weniger haare
und ist erst einmal nichts dazu gesagt
aber es ist doch stimmt schon also da
ich es mir nur die unteren haare färben
es ist ja besser fürs ha wald das sind
die gesunden haare die ja so man sagt
hat dass der oberkopf am meisten hat
wird weil durchstarten und so wendet den
kopf verdreht und dann doch keinen
seinen kopfkissenbezug hast dann brechen
die haare
hasi bis wohin sollen wir denn hochgehen
hatte sie das also ich würde gerne bis
also das ziehen soll auch glauben ja
weil die ich mag diese diesen anfangen
things nicht gewonnen
siehst du das oder wurde mal ganz kurz
besprechen so sicher ja
[Musik]
was haben wir gelernt
erst die lenkt dann die hand gehen
[Musik]
am schluss klappt also so wie ich jetzt
arbeite würde ich niemals unser lang
arbeiten okay nur für eure in
verarbeiteter einfach die haare mit dem
blick scheinbar noch mal hoch in die
jahre aber das machen wir eben gleich
wieder dunkel ja ja die entspannte
variante genauer low budget dabei aber
das obwohl etwas versprochen das ziel
sein pohlmann 2x
schwächer sein die links harry potter
charakter hmm ich bin gerade am
überlegen also schon ja klar harry so
lang ich fand halt immer die love hewitt
30 oder ich wollte heute mal sie seien
naja so wird es ja schon weiß haben man
musste schon recht das geld sein und das
ding ist halt auch dass du ja noch diese
anderen pigmente drinnen habe deshalb
also ich sag immer lieber zehn minuten
zu lange drauf als ziel und zu früh und
andere anstand kann man es nicht mehr
neutralisieren ja das war schon richtig
pes pes pes gelb sein aber ich hoffe
halt wirklich dass es nicht fleckig wird
weil halt durch die ganzen anderen
dingen zu sagen ja aber eigentlich war
das schön
[Musik]
wie lange brauchst jetzt noch für den
hinteren teil man die röllchen also ich
glaube ich bin sogar zehn minuten mit
der im hinteren teil fertig dann macht
die seiten das dauert wahrscheinlich
nochmals 20
meinst du denn die haarfarbe übrig
aber dafür silvester dieses jahr mit
meinem bruder feier weil mein bruder ist
ja zu hause alleine da sitzt hat jedes
jahr mit meinen eltern an silvester und
der ist schon jemand der halt kreuth
poker das sind was trinken der
trinkhalle auch vor gerne was man kann
ich glaube direkt mit kommst du willst
nicht betrinken
das ist ja alkoholfreier november und
dann die aber bestimmt übermorgen wieder
rappelvoll beim bdk pfandflaschen weg
bringen beim glas plastik container
einen daher jetzt wieder jetzt alkohol
dezember ich freue mich so sehr weil ich
muss jetzt wirklich die nächsten tage
jeden tag drehen sagt die polizei die
polizei sage youtube polizei ich das so
angekündigt im adventskalender was oder
was kriegst du die uns heute ich hab
glocken es ist so quasi das hat ich weiß
nicht wann das angefangen hat aber das
ist halt so ein trend früher offen
gewesen dass du halt einfach die
weihnachtszeit mitnimmt und gibt ein
paar youtube wo ich das mal so irgendwas
gerne geguckt habe dann habe ich
irgendwann selber an gefahren und hab
das noch nie so richtig absetzen sie
habe ich ganz gut durchgezogen aber
dieses jahr richtig durch dieses jahr
lebe ich nach meinen vier versprechen
und bin richtig
oder hast du das kind indem es zurück in
die heimat können auch schon zurück in
die 1
das ist ja das innere kind raste schon
von so was gehört
ich habe das auch hier fragte gut
megageil und dann habe ich auch ganz neu
wecke den optimismus indirekt wie
findest du was es da zu suchen
richtig tolle ratgeber jemand einfach
mal ein bisschen optimistischer erste
schirn wieandt elfer zugehört seine
seele will frei sein gibt auch auf
deutsch das buch ist wirklich der
absolute schutz weil das hat mich aus
meinen panikattacken rausgeholt
ich hatte ganz schön panikattacken und
dieses buch ist einfach sein für die
seele da geht es darum dass du dir
richtig bewusst wird wer du bist ja voll
also das ist auf jeden fall richtig
erfolgreiches jahr gewesen
für die psyche er klar also viele leute
sind noch nicht so ganz bereit also
diesen wandel dann auch zu machen mit
welchen privaten kreist sie sich so
dagegen wehren genau angst vor
veränderungen ja ja einfach hängen
bleiben auf dem was man schon gebot
genau und das gefühl dann entwickelt
sich weiter dann sollte man noch weiter
gehen und sich nicht aufhalten lassen
schön import uns dann einfach alle mal
das ja so eine pflicht zur stunde kostet
ja auch ordentlich war das spendenkonto
konto für einen großen traum
[Musik]
samstag donnerstag haben team und ich
date night für diesen koch tim raue
da kommt also der kauf nicht aber der
hat so ein lieferservice gegründet hat
und sagen as rom
dass du so ein vier sterne 4 links und
das cookies
das habe ich glaube ich schon mal gehört
von jemandem börsen fertig hat kommt ihm
okay okay jetzt frage ich timo ob er
lust hat kann bei live das ist so crazy
und dort jetzt werden
wie kriegst du die haare du machst du
mal so ja
ja warum nicht und dann mache ich dir
einfach hier vorne so ein paar ein okay
[Musik]
ja das muss jetzt gepflegt werden
konnten
es hat alles gesagt
[Musik]
schönig in zehnergruppen action das hier
geworden ist ich mache jetzt an wenn es
runter geht ist timo hier 3 2 1 die
highlights richtig krank ist
also wir hatten gerade eine
teambesprechung hier die haben wir nicht
aufgenommen aber weil heute der erste
advent ist ist quasi november war er ja
noch nicht an ja ich habe vorhin
geschrieben ist ja wasser trinken weil
sie nicht trinken nicht
[Musik]
entweder wir machen den ansatz
ins café kommt auch okay ja voll
supermarkt hat ja ja ja aber die bald
als bremen michael kauch schon so mein
bein fest dass irgendwie entlastet das
meinen nacken während in den körper
wir kennen ja ich helfe ihm klar zu
kommen wir dieser umstellung dann wäre
das leichter fühlen mit blond vierten
abschnittes oder was ich mache ja einmal
kurz polio sich dann einmal zur kamera
drehen
genau mein natürliches habitat wie lange
muss das jetzt drauf sein auf dem ansatz
halbe stunde
meine haare werden nicht abfallen
das drin na ja aber das ist ja gerade
deshalb sind meine haare
komisch nur
du hast sie einmal dann ja erst einmal
die bayern passen denn ich hatte heute
viel spaß und attacke
[Musik]
beide haben aus als hätte ich meine hand
des mieters richtung allerdings nicht
[Musik]
das wird nicht sparer ausgetragen das
kommt in masse ja wir verstreichen
nämlich nicht wie romantisch spachteln
genau und das ist jetzt aber auch schon
die tönung
ja das ist quasi nachdem blondieren hat
man ja mal so schöne gelbe haare geld
oder es wird weiß
[Applaus]
[Musik]
manchmal so gespannt aber zehn kilo
leichter ich sehe halt einmal lena ich
bin blind wiener ich bin ne bringen
[Musik]
minecraft ist oder ich habe mich zehn
coolness punkte einfach gerade so passt
es dann so vorgestellt
ich habe es mir genau wie handy geworden
wenn man jetzt sie sogar das war wie
eine streberin alter wenn jetzt so cool
ein super begeisterter ski helmen das
bekommen haben dann sage ich mache aber
morgen ersten richtigen wie so geil mit
make-up und sowie willst und die haben
wird so eine welle oder
so macht man halt besser am besten
einfach immer nur so ein bisschen oha
unseren schritten heraus also nicht so
eine runde also quasi nicht einmal
drehen sondern du kriegst das quasi nur
bei 1 1
die einrichtung ist es kurz so und dann
weißt du es ein kuss auf
[Musik]
ja es gibt schon hundertmal besser als
ist auf dieser seite
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dass wir mal früher haben sie mir einmal
die haben sogar nach vorne gefühl stimmt
für dein buch drin ist oder die für die
partei gestimmt da hat es zu sein
brauchst immer in den wahren
weißt du das noch ja ja das habe ich
nicht voll gesehen auf dem foto der
anreiz zu untersuchen scheinwerfer
verstanden ist vorher aufgenommen aber
jetzt kommt das nachher und dann so
carroll einfach so die strähne nach
hinten ziehen
timo zu meinen vorgelegt
alle lichter anmachen die wir haben
oh mein gott ich sie so cool aus ok
dieser award geht an timo und nicht fürs
einem monat kein alkohol anfassen und
herr thomsen für die haare und fröhlich
im ersten advent schön dass wir jetzt
auf locken tolle weihnachtszeit alltag
danke war mega erlebt was mal wieder mit
dir ich liebe diese spontanen sollten
teil und bleibt gesund und glücklich und
wir sehen sie morgen wieder dankeschön
und bis bald
ich traue mich gar nicht dass auch
einmal mein liebling schon verlieren so
wie schmeckt er bier timo sehr gut ich
fühle mich sehr reich mit den haaren und
das ist die hauptsache dass das was im
leben zählt und bis morgen tschüssi
copski